this is what you're saying and
everything felt alright until you said
you had a child for me personally
because I just think to myself marriage
is a hard work yes marriage is a hard
work and I think if you've got a child
to say like oh I need to we need to go
and find ourselves to me it just seems
like everything's just going backwards
yeah like you're finding that like you
got married first rather than find out
about each other then get married have
the child all I'm thinking about is yeah
you might be great co-parents but I'm
thinking of myself is
marriage is hard work yeah it is
to say like I'm gonna come back and
revisit it in another five years to me
that's just me personally it sounds
weird yeah
especially as your traditional are you
supposed to work at it no like I said it
wasn't my choice that wasn't my choice
so obviously it's not my choice that he
feels like he's not ready to commit into
that role again and that's what I mean
but you married him and that's what I
was saying that it seems weird because
you married him and they never like
you're starting
backwards so what I'm saying is
obviously in my situation I could try
find a new partner or husband or
whatever to marry it's just this country
I don't think is it enables that does
that make sense everyone's everyone's
trying to be City girl or city life and
that doesn't it's not something that I
would do so I feel like in this culture
in this Society I'm not going to find
the man I want to marry and when I say
three years I say three four years you
could be even next year whatever but
it's more if he's ready when he's ready
where he is I might be at the stage
where we're ready to work out again yeah
because that's what I find interesting
oh you know also can I just sorry for
cancer I just wanted to add like
listening to the whole story like Auntie
said it's it's like it's worked
backwards So within everything you've
said not once have I heard anything
about like your child how this impacts
your child and I'm not judging you for
that but that child has to live through
it and how does that
she doesn't know that we're separated
well I don't know but but the thing is
the thing is that's an assumption as
your daughter grit gets older she will
notice little things she will ask
questions and I think a lot of
relationship breakdowns don't ever
consider the children the children the
children don't choose to be here we
bring them here as adults and part of
being an adult is being responsible and
part of being responsible is making good
choices and making informed decisions
about the things that we do so I'm not
saying like your relationship is this or
that but what I am saying is a lot of
the time
um
children are kind of pushed to the side
and it's me me me me me even within the
partnership that's why it doesn't work
because everybody's thinking about
themselves finding themselves doing
their thing
um you know exploring themselves
whatever
children are growing up in fragmented
families and then they have no Direction
no they might have a foundation but they
don't have any direction yeah
I think I think
it feels as if like we're putting their
ownness just on her so her not what her
saying sorry not her so it's Soraya
saying that she wants to that the time
apart is needed yeah he also feels the
exact same thing that she's feeling so
he also needs to take time about I do
honest I do think that a lot of people
sometimes get into relationships and
they've got like a a me mindset and that
will not help relationships yeah but I
really believe that there are certain
things you need to work on on your own
yeah before you can then be in you can
then come together with someone on
beauty healthy relationships
sorry let me yeah let's finish for
example yeah say like say for example
say you've got like the things you've
been through previous Partners or
whatever if you do not work on that on
your own yeah you're going to enter a
new relationship and you're going to
bring up all that baggage into this new
situation it doesn't help you it doesn't
help the child I don't like when people
think that yeah yes children are
important yes you do whatever works for
you for your child but I have friends
who growing up where the moms have
stayed with the dads Because they stay
for the kids yeah and the kids have
grown up and said you know I wish you
left that because because you could have
gone and been at home you could have
been a healthy a woman who sort of
sorted out her life that's usually I've
been in a bit it's usually because my
mom the mom talks too much to the kids
you shouldn't know about yourself
the moms no I see this again and again
and again like moms moms will demonize
the dad and like talk [ __ ] about the dad
and then and then say oh you should like
why does a kid know that I did not know
that I disagree and the second and the
second thing is I I don't know her
marriage I'm not saying it's not his
fault too I said but I said the marriage
yeah but I'm saying like like for both
people like if you have a kid involved
like what you need to figure out
yourself figure it out in one Under One
Roof no but I disagree I disagree with
that because I have again out this is
what I'm saying is stuff that
conversation I've had with people who
have actually been in these in these
real life situations I know I have
friends whose mums literally did not let
them know what's their dad what piece of
[ __ ] the dad was they grew up to see
what a disappointment their father was
and they were like their mum to know why
would she left I think that yes people
are important I think that it's I think
that yes you know you should create the
best environment for your child and blah
blah blah all that is great absolutely
yes cool whatever but sometimes being in
the same household is not the best
environment for your child
every single statistical disadvantage
they're more likely to run away from
home they're more likely to drop out of
school they're more likely to be
homeless they're more likely to end up
in prison there's a direct correlation
between single parent homes and going to
prison
so you can you can you can say okay okay
you know there are certain situations
that are exceptions sure but if there's
not abuse there's not cheating
why are you why are you doing that to
your kid I'm supposed to put your kid
first go ahead how many parents from the
panel
well I just wanted to say this as well
um to go back to what you said when you
said no people you've spoken to have
said
and I wish you had left that or whatever
I wish you would expect it yeah or
separated that means that there were
things that were going on yeah that they
could see and feel an experience now how
do they know what it would have been
like without having their dad in the
household I think it's fair for children
to grow up to make their own decisions
about especially their fathers because I
feel in society as women we make a lot
of decisions for our children based on
how we feel at the time and we put our
children at a disadvantage
and I think for myself I always say this
but my dad
the things that he's done for me I'm not
saying oh that's a perfect my dad's not
a perfect man but there's things my dad
has done for me that have given me
strength inner strength that I can't
explain to you I can only show you the
way that I operate
um so for you to say like they've said
why I can't why didn't you leave dad
there must have been something in the
household that they were experiencing my
mum would always tell me as a basic rule
when you're raising kids they never see
anything that goes on whether it's
decision making whether it's fighting
nothing happens in front of the kids and
I brought this point up before when I
talked about women having or losing
their power because a lot of women want
to be at the Forefront of relationships
now where they dictate things my mom
said a lot of the decisions made in the
household my dad looked like he was
making the decision when really she had
a lot of influence on how the decision
was made that's not because that she
wanted to be at the front is because she
knew how to play her role in that
relationship when my parents did fight
it was never in front of us because as
many of you know I was just banned on
tick tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible